uh you'll recognize this shape right
this is a wonderful and very profound
shape it's so wonderful and profound
that uh mathematicians have discovered
it and rediscovered it um over the
centuries and it's easy enough that a
simple child can be told how to build
this right all it requires is whole
number addition um most of you guys know
that the simplicity of pascal's triangle
is um
matched by how profound the patterns are
in pascal's triangle that's kind of why
it's so famous
we know that the binomial coefficients
appear in uh in all of the all the
numbers our binomial coefficients and we
also know you can find all kinds of
things like
multiples of three they form weird
fractals and that kind of thing if you
never explore that you should definitely
google
fractals in pascal's triangle
but that's not what i want us to focus
on today and it's not going to give us a
result that we want to prove which is
the goal today okay so
here's the result i want you to focus on
there are let me just drag this up to
the right spot um several rows in
pascal's triangle that exhibit a really
strange and interesting property um you
can see the ones that i've highlighted
here these are the rows of pascal's
triangle where if you just ignore the
ones um the first term
is a prime number right so you can see
there's two that's prime three is prime
five prime seven is prime i don't think
i've missed any um this pascal's
triangle it goes up to uh 15 so 13 is
the last prime that we have there okay
um by the way sean your camera is on so
you may like to switch that off since
we're still recording but you know no
big deal it's okay all right there we go
now i want you to look really hard look
really hard at the rows of pascal's
triangle that i've highlighted which
have prime numbers in them
or that start with prime numbers rather
i want you to have a look at the rest of
the numbers in the row not the prime
numbers themselves but the numbers
alongside the prime numbers i wonder if
any of you spot that there's an
interesting property that all of those
numbers exhibit right in the fifth row
all the numbers in the fifth row have a
certain property
again ignoring the ones in the seventh
row uh those blue numbers right those
numbers all have a certain property the
same for the 11th row same for the 13th
presumably the same for the 17th i just
couldn't find a diagram that big
what's the property
can anyone see it
would it be helpful if for example
say it again say it again
all right so all the numbers in the same
row are multiples of the prime number
all the numbers in the same row
yeah all the numbers in the same row
are multiples of whatever row you're in
right so we usually call this the zeroth
row which makes this the first second
third row in the fifth row they're all
multiples of five i mean it's just five
and ten same with the tenth row if i go
down to the oh there we go the 11th row
you can see those multiples and then
here is the um the 13th row and all of
the multiples right
i claim that this is always true uh that
no matter what prime row you go up until
you will always find ignoring the ones
that all of the numbers are going to be
multiples of the prime number that
starts off that row that's my claim and
i'm going to ask you to try and prove it
now i'm going to give you
yeah i'm going to give you a few minutes
to go into breakouts and i i'm actually
not interested in you writing out a
proof i want you to try and sort of talk
through what might be your your tools um
to try and make a path through this the
writing will take too long i just want
you to discuss it okay i will give you a
single clue
which won't feel like a clue at all but
when i give you my proof you'll see why
it's important the clue is i'll let you
assume that all numbers in pascal's
triangle
are integers they're all whole numbers
you're like mr wu of course they're made
by adding right like we just we take the
top two and then we add them and they're
all whole numbers from the starts of
course they're whole numbers right um
that'll become a really important piece
of the puzzle so even though it seems
trivial take it and um you know don't
don't question the gift as i give it to
you so right now what i'm going to do
is i'm going to pop you into breakouts
and i'll give you i'll give you four
five minutes to have a bit of a chat
amongst yourselves
where are my breakout room controls here
they are so i'm i'm going to assign you
a bit randomly so if you have any issues
with technology please let me know i'm
going to send you in there i'll bring
you back at quarter 2 or you can signal
to me you're like we have no idea what
we're doing or we have an answer and
then we'll come back together to explore
solution okay so good luck here come the
breakout rooms
recording is back on just before i show
you the solution i have to tell you
there's a teeny tiny story behind this
uh question um which is that i actually
discovered this pattern years ago and
you can actually see if you if you go on
youtube and you search out pascals in
prime prime sorry
primes in pascal's triangle i'm pretty
sure my video is somewhere near the top
and you'll see me show this result with
no explanation to an extension 2 class
from a few years back and what was
really interesting is that one of my ex
students who was not in that class
who had become she was studying
mathematics pure mathematics at oxford
university um she uh messaged me and
said hey i like that video did you have
a proof for it and i said
back then actually no and then she said
well i'm a i'm an oxford mathematician
so i should be able to come up with one
and she came up with a solution that i'm
about to show you and i like the
question so much i almost put it into
your ap3 exam but
as you're about to see i feel like it's
it's a little bit cruel to put into exam
even though the question itself is
delightful so
i'm on the clock so let me try and walk
you through this proof
this is the claim right if p is prime
then
each of the numbers in the rows row of
pascal's triangle for that prime so
they're all of the form
p choose k this is using my binomial
notation should be
a multiple of p where you know n is a
whole number and also um this
restriction on k is what helps me ignore
the ones on either side right because
the first one would be p choose zero and
then the last one would be p choose p so
i'm just excluding those because the
ones are trivial and they're not that
interesting okay
so
how can we prove this blink and you'll
miss it i'm not going to write
everything but i will write the
important bits okay
um what what does this mean here this p
choose k we know it's actually shorthand
for some factorial notation right um you
might know it as like ncr and you might
have memorized it that way
and this is why it's important to know
what's underneath and not just rely on
your calculator to do the numerical ones
for you hopefully if you remember it's
going to be p factorial divided by
k factorial p minus k factorial so my
claim is that this is a multiple of pits
divisible by p okay
now the first bit of it this is not so
hard right because you can say wait a
second i know there's going to be a
multiple of p somewhere in the top
because p factorial by definition is p
times p minus 1 times p minus 2
multiplied all the way down until you
get to
1. so clearly p factorial on its own
is a multiple of p so i can say i.e
a multiple of p so that's great if you
just think about the numerator
however the reason why this property
only works for prime rows of pascal's
triangle like if you go back to pascal's
triangle
everything in the eighth row is not a
multiple of eight right it's because
you've got this denominator to contend
with right
if in the denominator you have some
number that cancels out like say eight
right if you've got like a two and a
four or a bunch of twos in here then
they're going to cancel and you won't be
a multiple of eight anymore as several
of the terms aren't so therefore i need
to be able to show not just that the
numerator has a factor of p i have to
show that it will never be
the the that number p will never appear
in the denominator so it can't possibly
cancel so it will remain up in there in
the numerator uncanceled so you have a
multiple of that number so how do we
prove that right
well think about this right if we think
about k factorial what is k factorial um
just like p factorial it's oopsie daisy
it's k times k minus 1 times k minus 2
and so on
just like before it ends at 1.
now i claim that the number p never
appears in this product no matter what
value of k you choose you're allowed to
choose p will never be one of these
numbers in here can someone tell me go
ahead and post it in the chat how can
you know that p will never appear
somewhere in this
a series of terms that are being
multiplied together can anyone give me a
suggestion
have a think it's even on screen
can you take us
okay so parhan you are right but i'm
questioning like there's going to be
prime numbers for sure in this um
sequence like i mean two and three are
there so there are primes in there um
and so i know that uh i'm questioning
where the p itself can appear right so
we'll get to the factorization in a
second but like how do i know p doesn't
appear somewhere earlier on right uh can
anyone tell me why
ah okay fantastic so sean and anger
uh famous musketeers together um have
both noticed right i restricted here
that zero uh sorry k has to be less than
p right um and that's because you can't
have like say if if i chose a number
right you can't have 11 choose 20. that
doesn't make sense right like how can
you choose 20 objects you only got 11 to
choose from right so we already knew i'm
sort of locked in right the k has to be
less than p so therefore p is never
going to appear in here because it's
it's bigger it's somewhere over here
it's k plus 1 or k plus two or something
larger right
now that's not enough to go to pahan's
point right um if say i said you know i
was if p was eight which it can't be
because p is prime but if p were eight i
wouldn't need eight to appear in this
product right because if i had say this
two here and a four
right then the two times four will
cancel with that eight
but this can never happen for p
why not well as pahana said p prime so
it doesn't have any other factors that
you can break it into right so none of
the factors of k factorial
can multiply to give together uh to
multiply together to give p right
so let me write that because it's
important since p is prime
none of
comma none of k factorials factors
can multiply
to give
p that's what it means to be prime that
there are no factors
and
p itself does not appear
p itself is not a factor
of k factorial because of that range
restriction that we mentioned about k
k rather
since
k is less than p so p will never appear
in this okay
now once you realize this uh once you've
sort of pulled this move you realize you
can do exactly the same thing for the
other term in the denominator i'm so
confident that you will get this once i
fully explain it that i don't need to
write it p minus k right p minus k just
like k
um p minus k has to be less than p
because k can't be zero um and so this
number is always going to be smaller
than p it might be p and p minus one p
and p minus two the p minus whatever
will always be smaller so i can pull
exactly the same argument here that i
did about k factorial i can say that
similarly for
not k factorial for p minus k
factorial so
p will never appear in that factorial in
that product nor will any of the factors
of p minus k factorial multiply together
to give p because they can't because p
is prime
so that's pretty much the guts of the
proof right you've got this multiple of
p from the numerator you can never have
some cancelling of p from the
denominator there's just one piece left
and it's the clue that i gave you right
at the start
i've got
oopsy daisy p choose k equals uh i guess
i could write it as p
times p minus 1 factorial all divided by
k factorial p minus k
factorial so you can see in this
numerator that's p factorial um so i've
pulled out the p so i pulled out that uh
i've pulled out that very numeral and i
claim that this part that i've
highlighted in green must be m right now
that's actually surprisingly more work
than you think and it's why i gave you
that clue right from the outset that
when we have a look at pascal's triangle
they're all whole numbers right so i can
just reason on the basis that since all
numbers in pascal's triangle are
integers they're whole
since we get them by addition not just
through this multiplication process
therefore i can say well this whole
thing has to be a whole number and p is
one of those factors so
i am done there's the proof okay now i
know i'm a little bit i'm a couple
minutes over time so i apologize for
that but i hope you can see how
important it is to be able to think
clearly about i mean all this factorial
stuff is extension one right but the
logic that you apply to the question is
definitely at a sophistication for
extension too
i will leave you with one final piece of
the puzzle to have a think about
prime numbers or rather pascal's
triangle is full of patterns like we
said and this pattern has to do with
prime numbers in particles triangle but
this is not the only place that is a
pattern with primes in pascal's triangle
for instance if instead of looking at
rows if you look at diagonals of
particles triangle which start with a
prime so here's
the diagonal that starts with two you
might notice you're like well of course
they're even numbers there are lots of
multiples of two here right you can just
climb up you've got all these multiples
of two
then we have a look at the next diagonal
that starts with a prime you've got
three and then six
for some reason you don't have nine or
twelve but then you get 15 21 you get a
whole bunch of multiples of three
in the fifth diagonal you've got a whole
bunch of multiples of five in the
seventh diagonal a whole bunch of
multiples of seven it feels a lot like
the result we just proved with the rows
but with this difference that there are
gaps right you you get sort of one one
one one multiple of two you get two two
two
two multiples of three
four multiples of five something weird
is going on here so i leave it as an
exercise to the reader and something for
you to play around with
to try and prove this result i'm gonna
tell you right now it's more complicated
than the previous one but even if you
don't get to an answer it's the thinking
that you apply that will help you to
tackle
unfamiliar questions and will reduce the
amount of times that you'll get into an
exam and think i've never seen anything
like this before
well now you have so if you do come up
with a result with a proof or something
like a proof you're welcome to send it
through mrs laser eye i'm happy to have
a look at it build on it or point you in
the right direction